hey this is presh talwalkar
a park contains a water fountain that
sprays water in the path of a parabola
the highest point of the stream of water
is one unit from the water fountain and
it's three units from the ground to the
highest point
the stream of water also reaches an end
point three units horizontally from the
water fountain which is two units
horizontally from the highest point
the question is how tall is the water
fountain
a version of this question was asked to
14 year old students in china
i think how you for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
to get started let's complete the path
of the entire parabola by imagining the
stream of water continuing to the left
side of the water fountain
since a parabola is symmetric the
distance from the highest point to the
left of this parabola will be two units
on the ground
in other words the distance from the
water fountain to the left endpoint of
the parabola will be one unit
we can now set up a coordinate system
suppose the lower left point is 0 0
then the highest point will be 2 comma 3
and the point on the right will be 4
comma 0.
we want to solve for the top of the
water fountain
this point will be 1 comma z and we want
to solve for the value of z
how do we do that
let's describe an equation for a
parabola that goes through the three
points 0 0 2 3 and 4 0.
so let's focus on these points
in this particular example we can use
the vertex equation for a parabola
we know that the vertex of this parabola
is equal to 2 3.
we can now disregard the point 4 0 and
let's substitute in the point 0 0
from here we get that 0 is equal to a
multiplied by negative 2 squared plus 3
and from here we can solve for a a will
be equal to negative 3 over 4 which is
equal to negative 0.75
we can substitute into the original
equation so we have y is equal to
negative 0.75 multiplied by x minus 2
the quantity squared plus 3.
from here we want to solve for the value
of z that corresponds to x is equal to
one
we substitute x is equal to one and then
we simplify
we thus get that z is equal to two point
two five units and that's the height of
the water fountain so that's a quick way
to solve the problem
but in some problems you cannot use the
vertex equation
so what do you do there if you don't
know the vertex of the parabola you have
to go to the general equation of a
parabola y is equal to ax squared plus
bx plus c
we then have a system of three equations
from these three points
so we first substitute in zero zero
this will allow us to solve that c is
equal to
zero using c is equal to zero we'll
substitute in the point two comma three
we can then simplify this equation
three is equal to four a plus two b
we then substitute in the point 4 comma
0.
we simplify this equation we have 0 is
equal to 16 a plus 4b
we now want to solve for a and b so
let's divide both sides of this equation
by 2.
we have 0 is equal to 8a plus 2b
from the last two equations we subtract
the second equation from the first
equation this eliminates the b variable
3 is equal to negative 4a which means a
is equal to negative 0.75
we then take this and substitute into
this equation
so we get that 3 is equal to negative 3
plus 2b
we simplify this equation and then solve
for b
b is equal to 3.
so we've now solved for a b and c
we can substitute into our equation for
the parabola
and then we want to solve for z
so we substitute that x is equal to 1
and then we simplify
we again get that z is equal to 2.25
and that's the answer
what an interesting problem
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you